it says so Japan has always been
influenced by the fact that there's very
few people I mean very very little land
and a lot of people mm-hmm very little
in a lot of people so so keeping things
being very polite was very important
being very clean that's very important
they're so close like when they have sex
isn't like you keep your voice down
you got a quiet when you [ __ ] unless you
you're taking my giant dong and then
then you're gonna sing their lineal this
is my impression of them every samurai
having sex with a woman yeah you think
it's that you think it fell out Hey hi
she's saying yes oh it sounds like he's
it's a cat I swear to God I had sex with
a Japanese woman when I was 21 I swear
on my life I'm not making this up and I
was and she was gorgeous and I was I was
doing my my 21 year old thing with my my
surprising piece my skinny body and my
surprising piece is surprised and I
swear to god she guess she was going and
I was like huh let me see that we got
there's nothing like a Japanese cow with
with howitzers she's got some [ __ ]
howitzers honor hey how about I forgot
this when we're in New York Buster you
know Buster's with us uh-huh
and we get in this uber and this is
black guy from Queens he's like well
it's not mother [ __ ] he's like joking
with us and these girls walk by and
there's like a big like Hospital
transgender girl he's like damn like he
goes oh hell no that's a [ __ ] dude
that's a dude and he goes you guys into
that [ __ ] and ones like no not our thing
man no everything is what are you into
and Buster goes I like Asian women with
big ass he goes [ __ ] that a unicorn
that's a unicorn [ __ ] any real
the [ __ ] Asian a big ass I don't know
you're never gonna see that we were
laughing so hard
that's dude how funny was it last night
at the Comedy Store with Jay Larson
I run off a bunch of Marines there's a
bunch of Marines there last night and me
and Brad just make him laugh [ __ ]
and Jay Larson was doing this a bit
where he pretend he was on a cell phone
it was so [ __ ] funny he's great he's
walking by everyone like you come to me
he goes man I heard you bombed I was
like I didn't bomb what are you talking
about he goes no that's what I heard I'm
sure yeah her job is good though and he
walks away and I'm talking all these
Marines he comes by goes no I shot dead
while Callan bomb but he's on the phone
he's like yeah no shop killed no but
yeah Brian come's makes another walk
back on another fake phone call and he
goes yeah yeah yeah Callens Gary I think
he's hey man all these Marines ah Jay
Larson's a funny [ __ ] super
funny man we've never had him on here
right we have we have a long time long
this time we go funny comic well I
talked to Pauly Shore last night you
saying he wants to come on yeah let's
get him on yeah Paul's got great stories
amazing stories we should definitely
have polygons you got probably be fun
right yeah Jim tell someone's old school
stories I important have him on that
would be fun pieces comedy history
actually oh yeah oh yeah him another
that did the legend I'll ask him about
the legend was his mother who was Mitzi
shore the great Mitzi shore who made it
something called a Comedy Store never
heard of it and and Mitzi shore he she
would let him cry in the crib and they'd
be like you know you should get him
because now he's learning how to bomb
he's learning I'm teaching him how to
deal with like you know people she was
just grooming on the babies are not I
mean it was too raising she's probably
joking yeah yeah no there's some epic
stories about her in the way she ran
things she was really sexy when she was
younger by the way yeah yes look out
look up young Mitzi shore and she and
even Polly like talks about how she did
have sex with the comics that's tough
man if that's your mom right she's such
a badass she did [ __ ] on her own died
the way she died no she was great Brian
but see if imagine you've been raised in
that atmosphere you're gonna be a little
[ __ ] up yeah you know I'm saying
that's gonna be tough well he on MADtv
he told a story a monologue about his
his stepfather and it was so funny but
tragic at the same time and it was so
good because it was true
I'll have him tell the story okay he'd
be over here right oh yeah dude he grew
up he grew up in a place where people
like Jim Carrey and Robin Williams and
Richard Pryor and the greatest legends
of comics where his babysitter's Latinos
babysitters were babysitters and also
starting out Roseanne Barr how about
that Sam Kinison Sam Kinison was his
babysitter you know that no that's
hilarious to me that's amazing
you're the King chainsmokers closer no
you know the Halsey song she has some
[ __ ] hit I don't care bro I'm not
part of the fan club all right but I do
celebrate it I don't like her how about
that I really I just added she sucks you
know I've decided your piece of [ __ ]
five years nobody'll know her name there
I said you broke will save them those
are white rapper friend that's 30%
oh no that's 30% and you were turning
red now if you say one more thing that
Halsey jay-z uh my job snow I just came
to you're white Walker
dude you just stuck your fingers in my
[ __ ] neck that was 30% I could have
just peeled your thumbs off I wish you
could dude I feel better about myself I
kind of just got Oh what's a heavy it's
a heavy crown no I could kill you you
know I'm saying like it's kind of you
reckon you could kill me with just your
two hands like that oh yeah you know I
don't know it's a it's a heavy it's a
lot of weight to carry around so I know
for an argument I just don't know you
wanna like [ __ ] it I could kill you no
because I would have just thrown my in
it weird so if you're losing your you
just yeah it's like [ __ ] it and kill you
for it are you like a man I think this
like cool dead and dead and like a lot
of weight is on my shoulders thing not
killing you something really yeah I
haven't we talked [ __ ] about Halsey I'm
gonna carry an aisle around here
brahmacarya small knife and uncie that's
I wish you would cuz then I wouldn't be
like I could just cuz I could just unzip
you yeah
then I feel more threatened awesome you
like
like the middle you're on I feel a
threat I do this I go and I feel zero
threat really yeah at all times for me
yet I'll carry a [ __ ] please diri
like I would respect you more you know I
opened you up I wish you would carry a
knife dude now I I want you to apologize
to Halsey before we do it and I don't
care if you kill me cuz I'm gonna stand
by my principles you know I'm worried
that if you come at me again I'm gonna
meet you halfway here meet me in the
middle yeah meet you Toby
Anaheim card you have c 233 which is a
pretty stacked card did they say why
they canceled it they didn't say why but
everyone's saying because there's also
the Bellator heavyweight tournament in
that same weekend the TJ Dolorosa who
Doe was moved toward so just a bunch of
different things yeah you know that's
one that Ben Askren supposed to be
fighting on with Robbie Lawler yep Ben
he's supposed to be on below the belt
that week well there you go they're just
moving it forward I heard some there
motherboard in Anaheim though or
somewhere I don't know so they're
worried about pay-per-views that's
what's going on and selling alright
alright why don't you get one more MMA
thing that we were talking about this on
blow the belt so Brock Lesnar for
whatever reason in Asada's website
showed that he had two tests and then it
magically disappeared like later on
someone found out about one of the tests
disappearing and then who thought I made
a statement saying that it was just a
technical issue that it wasn't even
supposed to be there in the first place
right and then the guy who looked this
up this guy Tim space said he looked at
every other fighter on the on the
registry and that this is the only
fighter word this technical issues time
never happy huh I don't listen when
you're in business to Brock Lesnar I'm a
big Brock Lesnar fan I think's
phenomenal fighter yeah yeah it's you're
dealing with shady business you do some
kind of some shady business that's the
that's the game you play with it and
Nowitzki also said he has access to all
the database stuff and he goes yeah I
would have seen this and it was never
there in the first place it seemed super
super Sheen but he works for them so
you know yeah okay okay I'll have a
problem with it all right cool min all
right and I'm a huge Nowitzki fan but it
is what it is man that's what it is
shady be Shady let Brock do his [ __ ] man
history has been made here in the US the
first transgender boxer wins by
unanimous decision
okay so I'll hold a hold hold hold hold
thirty-four-year-old former Olympic
boxing hopeful not only made
professional fighting debut and beat
Hugo
so was it a female-to-male yeah she said
that she'd give me bat mail yeah and one
and one damn it's impressive
now now for the feminist if it was a
male who felt like a woman went to
female compete against females we up in
arms but we're celebrating a female
well that's because that females are at
a disadvantage physically with fire bro
we're all the same
yeah these feminists we're all to say
bro all the same yeah okay yeah yeah guy
female Navy SEALs you have a gaijin
Juwanna Mann go in fight boxing let me
know how that works out for everything
yeah good we're all the same good for
her for [ __ ] competing with the men
and doing well that's impressive arey
impressive don't see the person that he
fought yep this is his record oh you
gotta start somewhere bro yeah okay now
Hugo is probably a little embarrassed
okay probably back to his [ __ ]
country of Mexico and they go who'd you
fight he goes oh dude yeah and then they
go really let us look into and go hey
Hugo
word on the street is you got beat up by
it he's got [ __ ] x-chromosomes
everywhere
yeah a lot of sex acts promises because
they're not macho at all in Mexico No so
basically you might want him down boy
Hugo might not be for you bro that's
throwing six I've been in jujitsu
classes where back in the day when
Japanese fighters would come in like
like in hensel's place in places like
that and Japanese fighters would come in
and they were guesting they were guests
they were rolling they were usually
fighted him medicine pride mmm and
they'd be paired up with a woman they
wouldn't wrestle whether they bow out
maybe I'd know I saw that with my own
eyes a couple times yeah I don't say
that I used to pass like
when we trained Denver with like
Michelle Waterson like karate hottie I'm
so much Baker yeah and like we get pair
up like I'll probably go with small yeah
I'm so much boy this like when I get
much out of it now I'm gonna get a
raging boner and my friends can make fun
of me so probably go so now she's so I'm
not a sexist oh ha I'm just yeah she's
but this guy this one for Jesus so this
was blatantly like I don't know I don't
oh yeah that's that's their cultural
thing yeah when you see my back rippling
I pull myself up like a champ like a
champ through 30 times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gift it's a gift
it's a gift